the jurgen experience
um but then there are the people who are
selling the antidote to their fears like
in in the book i call these people the
dread merchants right the people who are
going to sell you the bunker
you know jim baker and his son oh yeah a
gym based food um and his survival
waters
how how amazing are those buckets of
food that you could use as the base of a
table i've seen that whole
video i love those and he talks about
using them as porta johns
and uh yeah but he sells the bible
buckets as well have you ever buckets
what's a bible book it's just a bucket
full of bibles you know
just just in case why do you need more
than one bible i know
yeah well maybe you got a big family
maybe you want to go old testament if
[ __ ] gets really weird
have you ever seen the the vic burger
remixes of the gym yes i have oh man
they are so much fun yes i got really
addicted to those when i was working on
this project it was kind of my
it became almost like a um a mantra you
know
having these running in the background
it's so strange that he
was the guy that was attached to the
jessica hahn
controversy back in the 1980s i mean i
remember that yeah do you remember the
jim baker like he had had an affair
with this woman and it became for
whatever reason this big news
that's the same guy because then we we
still expected people to be guided by
their moral compass you know
everyone's a hypocrite now right
remember then there was jimmy swagger
got caught with a hooker
and he was crying i have soon yeah do
you remember that
you remember that that was good yeah no
one confesses anything anymore no one in
prison
bible bucket yes i love that one
of bibles why not that's some only 50
bucks
that's a pretty good deal how many bar
how many bibles you get 24.
why i think it's what it says should we
get a bucket of bibles i feel like we
should have one at this point
get one i feel like we should have one i
don't want to feed the beast but you
should you should get one
if he gets 50 bucks from me what the
[ __ ] we need at least a table
table worth right right a table's worth
of bibles six buckets
can you get how many buckets makes a
table but that
shouldn't we get the food we should just
get the bibles well one bucket of bibles
and five buckets of food
but his [ __ ] i love watching him feed
the audience
from the giant trough you can get real
good
freeze-dried food that'll last forever
you know yeah [ __ ]
yeah so what the [ __ ]
creamy potato soup oh my god look at
that
shovel yeah yeah and they do a big thing
of rice and then they do
and they mix it all together you know
big bucket of slop just pour it on top
of it google peak
refuel dot com this is my friend chad
mendes has a really
delicious um company that
they make actual i think is it
freeze-dried i think his stuff is freeze
dries
or dehydrated i'm not sure but the
people are doing it now
yeah people are doing it now where you
can keep this stuff forever this is
my buddy chad's stuff this is really
good for you it's actually delicious
and healthy yeah and he's doing mylar
bags too that's that's much better than
doing buckets
yes and he's uh chad is a former ufc uh
fighter who's a great guy who's actually
a hunter and
he makes every everything's organic and
really healthy and
and when you re uh constitute it it
actually tastes good
so you don't have to buy that gym baker
[ __ ] you can actually buy this check
this out
i went to this i went to a community in
uh just outside of dallas
and uh they were this is a budding
prepper community
and they had built this this 50-foot
fountain ringed by the four horses of
the apocalypse oh christ
right i mean it's like in a you know in
a rural county
in a town with like 300 people you know
they bought all this land it's like it
was a square mile of land
um and it had these these uh sort of
green lagoons in there that were dredged
out for for
uh grazing cows at some point and they
were going to
revitalize these into these kind of like
crystal blue lagoons with white beach
sand and they were going to build a
bunker community in there
um called trident lakes so the the lakes
or the uh the blue lagoons
and he told me that their their plan was
to do a kind of outer perimeter wall
around this
that was going to be a a giant berm
around
shipping containers so essentially the
wall would be
hollow and he said he was going to fill
it with buckets
of food and whatever and i just i kept
imagining
you know jim baker's bible buckets just
lined up down the walls of this thing
you know
to keep intruders out of the [ __ ] 12
foot high wall of bible buckets
[Applause]